un lieu mythique toujours autant prisés
par les new yorkais pour se dégourdir
pour prendre une bouffée d'air frais ce
que l'on voit moins bien en bulles et
ici comme ailleurs à new york ce sont
les touristes central park en accueille
habituellement des millions chaque année
cette place devrait normalement être
bondé çà et là
pratiquement personne pour acheter des
souvenirs ou pour monter à bord des
autobus de tours guidés et ceux qui
auraient voulu se divertir se heurte à
des portes qui resteront closes pendant
encore des mois comme ici à broadway
fermé pour des raisons sanitaires
new york doit composer cette année avec
un déficit de plusieurs dizaines de
millions de visiteurs un coup dur
le tourisme est un secteur clé de son
économie les affaires sont mauvaises
confirme ahmed bilici ils interpellent
les passants
mais son cheval istanbul attire
davantage les caresses que les passagers
il explique que son métier forcé à
l'arrêt pendant des mois à new york
explique centre de l'aco vide espérait
se refaire une santé durant les fêtes
qui débute bientôt avec l'action de
grâce mais ça se présente mal et pas
seulement pour les qualifier un match il
ne sait pas s'il pourra tenir avec les
comptes est payé sa famille son cheval à
nourrir cette question ne se pose plus
pour un million de new york est la
pandémie a eu raison de leur emploi
au centre des distributions de
nourriture les files s'allongent yolanda
attend depuis des heures j'étais
employée au centre-ville dans un hôtel
j'ai travaillé toute ma vie
maintenant j'ai besoin dead
explique-t-elle elle risque d'avoir
besoin encore longtemps
un récent rapport prévoit que new york
pourrait ne pas renouer avec son
influence à touristiques habituels avant
la fin de l'année 2025 ici un libéro
radio-canada new york